okay so we've been talking a little bit
about Bernie Sanders not yet having
released his tax returns supposedly he's
going to be releasing them early next
week
he should I've said this before I'm
gonna take an audience question about
this tomorrow I think it's really
important to understand that with Donald
Trump he doesn't want people to know
that he's not as wealthy as he claims to
be there is speculation with Bernie
Sanders that it's the opposite that
bernie is wealthier than maybe people
imagined that he is or maybe his
rhetoric might imply that he is and
there are more and more people pointing
out including on corporate media but
also in kind of the independent media
circles that Bernie Sanders is probably
a millionaire and that this will sort of
put into question his credentials as the
fight for the little guy candidate that
he claims to be and I want to just
destroy this narrative completely and to
do that we've got to break it down into
two parts okay
the first part is let's assume Bernie's
a millionaire what does that mean
generally in terms of his financial
financial position and then if indeed he
is a millionaire what does this mean in
terms of his political positions and how
we should interpret them okay and this
is I've not decided who I'm supporting
in the 2020 primary but this is a really
dumb criticism criticism of Bernie
Sanders and I'm gonna tell you exactly
why on multiple levels first of all I
know that there are some people in the
audience who will go nuts about me
saying this and they'll say David you
are so disconnected from the reality of
what's going on in the United States
Bernie Sanders being a millionaire at
age 77 is not a huge deal and it's also
not exorbitantly wealthy and I know
people will say David there are tons of
people who can never retire who have not
even $10,000 in savings when they're in
their mid 70s and I understand that and
that's not untrue but let's just look at
the data okay let's assume Bernie
Sanders has a net worth of a million
dollars just to pick a number maybe it
ends up being more I don't know Bernie
Sanders is 77 years old okay 1 million
dollar net worth at age 77 is not
statistically unusual this is not my
opinion
I'm just telling you what the data is if
you look at 2016 Federal Reserve data
for people in the United States age 75
to 79 the mean wealth is 233 thousand
dollars and the median wealth is 1.1
million I am not making a comment on
anything other then for Bernie's age
it's a fact that half of the country has
more wealth than Bernie and half of the
country has less wealth than Bernie
that's what it means that Bernie
basically has the median net worth for
someone his age so when we talk about
Senators with 40 million dollars in all
of this Bernie Sanders is not in that
league okay he's been working for 60
years he's been earning money a good
salary as a member of the House of
Representatives and more recently the
Senate presumably he's been saving money
compound interest is a thing and I know
that the term millionaire is very loaded
and in a sense it shouldn't be in this
particular case if Bernie's net worth is
1 million dollars or 1.1 million dollars
he's in the fiftieth percentile for
people his age using the median as our
indicator those numbers are also 3 years
old meaning that 1.1 million today might
more closely be the 48th percentile or
the 46th percentile I've not seen 2019
data so that's number one all right but
I don't even care about that we should
know the numbers but there's a really
more important issue here you can be
poor and advocate for policies that help
the rich look at the 2010 Tea Party
movement you had people who weren't rich
and we're likely never going to be rich
pushing for tax cuts for the rich and
cuts to capital gains taxes and stuff
that would never affect them in the same
way you can be median wealthy or rich or
whatever and advocate for policies that
are going to help the poor in middle
class
Trump super wealthy if his policies were
good for the lower and middle class who
cares that he's super wealthy bernie has
made ultra clear what his policies are
the fact that he has achieved as a 77
year old man median net worth in the
United States doesn't change
what his policies are as long as we
believe that his policies are the right
one there are rich people like Tom
Steyer and other so-called patriotic
millionaires even billionaires who have
a ton of money but they have the right
ideas now the the one criticism you can
make is you can argue it's harder for
someone who's been super wealthy for a
really long time to even understand the
plight of those who aren't wealthy
that's a fair criticism but then let's
actually see if they get it or if they
don't Bernie Sanders has not been super
wealthy his entire life by every
indication he has achieved roughly
median net worth at age 77 when Trump
confuses health insurance and life
insurance it's pretty damn clear he
doesn't get it he's out of touch he
doesn't know what the day-to-day life of
the average American is I've seen no
evidence that Bernie doesn't get it and
that's sort of where it starts and ends
for me and I think any factions of the
left that are getting after Bernie for
maybe having a net worth of a million
dollars make a 180 and get the hell away
from this argument because it is a
losing argument if you disagree with me
if you think Bernie being a millionaire
is problematic in some way I want to
hear from you i'm on instagram at david
pakman and the show is on instagram at
david pakman show follow us there and
let me know what you think today's
program was made possible in part by
simple habit an app for iOS Android and
web browser that gives you access to
more than 2,000 guided meditations you
can try it free for one week by going to
simple habit comm slash Pakman simple
habit has meditations made specifically
for anxiety falling asleep overcoming
procrastination getting focused there's
a meditation for almost anything you are
dealing with in life and there is
constantly new scientific research
emerging about the benefits of
meditating regarding your physical
health your mental well-being your
social life your cognitive performance
it's a long list
I personally make meditation part of my
day I've been doing it for a while and
simple habit makes it incredibly easy to
stick to a meditation routine each
guided meditation is just five minutes
long
they have meditations specifically
designed for waking up for your daily
commute when you get home from work
every part of your day
the massive variety of different kinds
of meditations that simple habit offers
is what really sets the app apart and
they just won the 2018 Google Play award
for best well-being app you can try it
completely free for a week by going to
simple habit calm slash Pakman I think
you'll love it I've put a link right
underneath this video